I honestly think there's more
traditional when than traditional women
nowadays when you go to get advice you
should only go to get advice from people
that you want to Aspire to be like
people really care about you especially
women sing Single and a certain age they
feel insecure they feel afraid what
people will say I did that because I
really want to know if he would go to
those extents for her
what'd you think
women
watch it up
because it depends actually depends on
the dynamic of the the marriage like if
she's like a stay-at-home wife
then and he's like doing the most and
he's You Know Rich and whatever
she just does you know the standard
stuff that women do you know cooking
cleaning or whatever he'll come home
bring Gucci all of that stuff she's
and then if she like not saying that
there's some girls I'll do it but you
know if you divorce them you're taking
half you know he might have worked
harder for it but you can still take it
okay what about you what do you think
about it no one no one
exactly
that's sad bro oh why'd you say no one
benefits why do you think that marriage
is difficult it's a lot of time work
energy and so I don't see like a man or
a woman who's gonna like hope for women
because or men I think it's really hard
for both to be committed to be there to
be a good parent to you know be dealing
with your personal life your do you
think it might be harder for one party
harder it's hard for both but do you
think it might be harder for a woman or
harder for a man I think it's equally
for both hard for both because the
responsibility is for both so
in a marriage in a different ways let's
say demands the provider but he is also
needs to be in a work where he hates his
boss but he needs to be there so
different kind of challenge but
difficult for both for sure
okay so
um in a relationship earlier I asked you
there's always a method there's a method
to my madness in it while I ask the
questions the way I ask them because
earlier I asked you who do you think is
easier to please in a relationship and
you said man
yes so if that's true and we've agreed
to that yes you've already agreed to
that yeah yeah so in a marriage which is
a relationship
why is it all of a sudden 50 50.
because I think like uh the
responsibility when you have a family is
not you're not talking about in a
relationship marriage marriage in a
marriage I think is is 50 50 if someone
gets sick the other needs to take care
so let's say is difficult for both I
don't see like for women or from America
who takes more Advantage because I don't
think but don't you see how that kind of
contradicts what you agreed to earlier
but you said differently if it's easier
to please a man in a relationship let's
say man it's very simple women can do 10
tasks at the same time but men just
can't do one so man is super simple how
does that mean how does that change
anything women can be driving doing
their makeup be on the phone at the same
time we talk about men and women
pleasing each other you're talking about
the women can multitask what are you
talking about no because you were
telling me earlier about us if it's
easier to please a man and a woman would
never be easy to please because in her
mind would be thousand things going over
you never guess what is there okay so if
we go with what you're saying a man is
easier to please correct and a woman is
harder to please because she's got a
million things going on in her mind plus
hormones and emotions and all of this
stuff so when you get into a marriage
what changes to make it now 50 50.
the commitment it's the responsibility
to keep together it's like half and half
I don't see like for one side it was
going to be better comparing to the
other for me it's equal
I want to kind of go back back because
you said about structure I feel like
when he was also talking about the wifey
material thing what you listed as a guy
um
when you said it and I'm I'll take it on
because you're a guy it didn't sound
hard like I'm not trying to like put I
could
oh but it just didn't sound that hard
and then for my idea of what like a guy
would have to go through in terms of a
marriage it just sounds like more work
on their end like I don't know if that
makes sense what's more work for the men
are the women for the men like I feel
like the the list of things that he said
about for a wife to do that and to just
be there for them and do the just simple
stuff yeah just care and do the simple
stuff like cleaning and with that like
this is really simple in my eyes and
then he's going out as you said he could
hate his boss his boss could be bullying
him but because if it's a dynamic of a
marriage where he's the provider the
protect and all that he's gonna have
that in his head and he's gonna like
fight and continue doing this stuff so
really and truly I I don't want to be
mean but I kind of do I disagree with
what she's saying that if he was going
by the structure that I just want to say
that but yeah what do you think about
what she just said
different opinions yeah it's just
different opinions
I mean but like
you haven't really come up with any
logical rebuttal like you're just saying
no it's just different because
commitment that's what you said really
yes it's really hard for you to be in a
commitment to be with a person it
doesn't matter if you're in a
relationship
which is
involve a lot of a lot of things like in
bureaucracy change your name and it
changed their life just Society how does
that
sorry sorry but like you're just saying
you're just saying anything you you just
have your way you have your opinion and
you just want to stick to it regardless
even if you have nothing to uh you know
no evidence or no logic or nothing to
back up what you're saying just talking
at this point like that that made no
sense can I can I ask you a question
what do you think
what do you think a man won out of
marriage if you give me three things
what the guy what the man whatever give
me three things just three
wow
that's good question because most of the
time they get married because the women
are the one all the time asking and
being like right but if a guy's okay if
a guy's thinking what his wife would do
for him what's one thing she would do
like the first thing that comes to your
head
you're in a marriage for a man yeah
what did he not get until he was married
in the old days
family children how did you get a family
okay okay
that's okay okay that's fine that's one
he does get children out of a marriage
what else
how does how does he get the children
how do they make their children no sex
of course okay so do you think sex is
important to men in a marriage
yes okay what what do women want out of
a marriage is stability okay and what
would you say that you get that through
long-term commitment right
so what if I told you one in four
marriages were sexless one in four I
believe so do you who is it harder for
then if we're getting the commitment
from him but they're not getting the sex
from us
wow would that would that change your
point of view a little bit
no no I agree I know like there's a lot
of marriage with there is no sex
involved and it's normal but
that's
that's our people they are different
like well I'm my whole point is that
like as the women we in that deal it's
not a fair deal because we get the
protection and provisioning and the
long-term commitment which is what we
want right I mean unless you marry the
guy that you know assuming you don't
marry a guy that's gonna run right but
the men it's like the most important
thing that men want
is to bend the girl over backwards you
know what I mean and so it's like they
don't even they don't even get that out
of it and so it's like
it's like the number one thing that they
want we can't even give them so it
almost becomes an unfair deal because
these guys get married and they're
thinking dang I get this unlimited sex
with my wife and then she's like nah I
got the kids I'm good she's like Nabi
I'm friends with this divorce attorney
and he said it's really common for women
to stop sleeping with their husbands
after they get their children I I
believe that too
for uh the membership big up to you and
we got to ND for the membership yeah
bigger big up for joining Sparta yeah
appreciate you I've been out to all the
members in the chat there's a lot of you
still we got to you look man
um
yeah you you just don't get it cool
all right so
um where are we at on this super chats
man
um
all right we got to
Daniel he says men face hardship Miss
Brazil that's what makes us stronger
mentally physically socially and
financially we got to bofar for the
super chases imagine willing to die
along alone alone over IG big red we got
to check out um he says women should
value their ideal man's leadership as
they would their boss why don't they
being like the modern women probably
respects our boss more than the man that
she's in a relationship with would you
like do not think about that
because if your boss tells you you need
to come in at 8am you're probably gonna
do it and if he says you gotta leave at
9 00 PM you're probably gonna do it
because you value that job and your
career
whereas if your guy says oh can you
delete your Instagram now I've got to
think about it
don't you think
oh
I don't thank you guys I told producer
we need that we need them sound effects
but where's our soundboard you want to
sound bad yeah sound bad soundboard even
blessing's been slacking that's what I'm
saying then slacking I've been asking
for this for ages yeah where is the
soundboard blessing
get your mic on oh yeah super shot guys
you're gonna get some book oh yeah yeah
oh yeah not rule rule talk you lot Super
Chat and we'll get the soundboard
because I need to get that because it's
too perfect yeah and a megaphone is all
yeah I was in all right cool um all
right cool let me get to a question all
right
do you think modern women waste their
best years
what do you think what okay I'm gonna
awesome just pearly mama what do you
think about it do you think do you think
modern women waste their best years
straight up yikes what do you think
about it because why are you wasting
your time tramping around with all these
people when you can pick the one and be
with that one forever and that's the one
that goes You Know You're On The
Headstone with and I just don't
understand why I literally don't
understand I think it's everyone's dream
is to find the one but at the time we
believe it's been difficult yeah like
and the first problem in the
relationship is so easy to you to be
replaced the guys just go on the day
trip and find 10 000 dates next day so I
think it's very difficult to keep
together in a relationship because now
the people have a feeling that's so easy
to find the day to find someone
so I think like
for this part technology doesn't help
much and I don't I don't disagree I mean
I think that's that is a hundred percent
true
however I also think that you know in a
marriage you know I mean Hannah would
like to think her dad's perfect he's not
I'm not like it's not a perfect marriage
for sure however we have you know a bump
in the road here and there every time
you go through a different relationship
you have another bump in a road except
it's like a mountain and so why not be
in a situation where you are evolving
and growing and evolving and growing
together and I can tell you that our
relationship started out in a really
horrible place and can I share this do
you care
yeah Greg yeah okay okay so
um you know first my husband and I were
we met through my brother my sister was
engaged in my husband's brother and they
never married so that's a pretty big
bump and then I get pregnant had a baby
gave him up for adoption
that's a really big [__] bump talk
about a bump that's like not a bump
that's like Mount Everest and then we
managed to build the company have a
family you know get married have a
family and have him come back into our
lives that's another big bump every one
of those are hard but the only things in
life you're proud of are the things that
were hard so why not be willing to go do
the hard things
because our generation we are not strong
like you are I think like I don't I
don't agree I look at you and I I
literally am sad because I think like I
want that for you I want you to think
differently I want you to think that to
Value yourself and to think like you are
worthy of that and there's not you know
just talk about the men mostly I think
like the guys who are attending the
provider who's going to protect the
house I wish all the men could represent
this kind of security but our generation
I have the feeling they maybe they've
been with less trauma less things they
are not the tough there's less of them
there is less of them but there's also
less competition for good quality women
I mean there's so you know the just let
all the trash hang out at the gutter and
go rise up
no that I agree that I agree I think
like the same ways difficulture find the
man is just go to find the traditional
women can I um so we we've kind of been
talking about
traditional modern I'm just going to do
an experiment three there's three guys
in here right do you want to protect and
provide for your girl yes or no depends
on the girl oh come on
not by yeah yeah if you want to protect
and provide for your girl yeah do you
want to protect and provide yep there's
three right there but it's like
interesting because I'm asking you guys
more traditional questions and the
answers don't line up so like I honestly
think there's more traditional men than
traditional women nowadays I think the
shortage is an RN not theirs I think
there's a lot of men that want to
protect and provide but like who are
they going to protect and provide for
women that don't listen to them why
would you protect them and that's why I
said that doesn't listen and that's why
I said the pins that's that's why like
obviously as a man like you are going to
want to be in that position because if
you are protecting and providing it does
put you in the position of leadership
and Authority in your household like
with your woman but or in your
relationship or whatever but
unfortunately like a lot of us guys
let's say guys of this era we are coming
across a lot of girls that this on know
wifey material this is not bro and it's
not I'm not saying they're bad people
I'm not saying they're horrible people
or they can't change but I'm just saying
like bro like we're meeting a lot of
girls that when you meet them they're
not wifey material bro recreational use
we can be friends that smash or whatever
like that's it like and that's it
and you know there's certain things I've
said like there's things I've we've
we've discussed and I've said things in
a logical for most logical standpoint
that you just like you just totally
rejecting without any logic base or you
just well this is what I think this is
just my opinion the world doesn't run on
just just it causes your opinion the
world runs on logic and what makes sense
and there's equations to everything like
do you get what I'm saying and if you
just try to live your life of some fairy
tale Disney movie I'm sorry like it
doesn't work it doesn't work it's not
real it's not reality the moms die in
Disney movies huh most of the man's die
in Disney movies think about it Dumbo
wife die or mom died Bambi mom died
Frozen mom died
wears Snow White's mom I don't know
I respond the whole thing tonight
holy [__] there's not a single mom
that's alive in Disney
Pocahontas but it's like it's like eyes
we're told as like a society that we can
just we don't have to listen to men we
can do whatever we want in our younger
years and at the end of the day there's
going to be a fairy tale waiting or
we're gonna be alone and we're really
gonna be happy with it and I I just
think that's a lie I I I just I think
either you make certain choices and you
don't get the men you want or
you know you you wind up by yourself and
I just genuinely don't believe the women
you're talking about are happy I don't
think they would prefer to be alone
rather than with a family
subject is very subjective I'll talk
about happiness because like it depends
for women I know a lot of women who
after lost their husbands they never got
married and they are happy
I know people who started dating they
are happy so I think it's very
particular and unique it depends of the
the human being to remember being and
happiness do you think they're happier
by themselves or with their husbands
it depends on the hands but sometimes
they're there better by themselves for
sure it's always going to depends if
each case is very different or the other
some people are happy together some
people are not so it's very like like I
said like on social media we just watch
the top of the iceberg we don't know
what the problems what they're being
through like you can tell about Shakira
now with everything she's going through
she's crying Miley Cyrus everyone has
personal problems and now they they put
on social media but they've just put the
part they want to they not the whole
thing so I think it's very it's changing
the idea of course everyone's would like
to have a family but I also believe that
people now have a different kind of
family a person who is single but got a
dog or a cat is their family I don't
know why Shakira left him not a good
move on her part
yeah she should have stayed Shakira yeah
I mean he's he was yeah okay yeah yeah I
mean look he was cheating sure but I
mean she You could argue she was
cheating by shaking her ass at the Super
Bowl like it's like women always wanna
women always want to say oh it was the
man
but you were you were shaking your butt
at the Super Bowl how that's not loyal
so it's like we always wanted we always
want to blame the men always blaming the
men but it's like he got 10 ass pictures
on Instagram you've been shaking your
butt for all of these men to see and
then he steps out once and he's the bad
guy oh come on what do you think about
what Paul just said
I don't think that's much still online
what's mad
he knew she was when he met her like
she'd been doing that and she knew you
know I mean no but she's been shaking
her ass like you're right but she but
she knew who but she knew who she he she
knew who she was with when she met him
if you if you're gonna date the top rich
and powerful men in society right that
also are famous which what percent of
famous men are loyal you know what
you're getting yourself into you're not
done she might not have been able to
cope with it anymore you can't say to
someone just stay I don't know what
maybe he could have maybe he was sick of
coping with his his wife shaking her
butt on Instagram
my whole point is like women always want
to point the figure at men and say oh
it's the man it's the man oh like we
always want to look at cheating with no
Nuance like oh he cheated but what did
she do and you also don't know why he
did but she didn't cheat though but I
get where I get what you're trying to
eat I'm saying I think it's the same
problem
guys never are honest when they want to
break up I think they start to behave
like
it's like a lot of times like my mom was
saying earlier like people aren't
perfect and so she's gonna say oh he
cheated okay yeah he cheated but I mean
you could argue you're cheating by by
showing your body on Instagram that's
not very loyal to your husband but he
that's that's what it doesn't make sense
to me because if you didn't stop it why
did you why did you go to a girl like
that then like it doesn't make sense to
marry a girl probably because
it doesn't matter right there but they
but the whole point is they probably
match I mean she's putting her butt on
the Instagram he's probably cheating
they probably match as a couple like
that's that's what they're doing so that
my whole point is she wants to go on
social media and play victim and say oh
I did nothing wrong
okay yeah Miracles miracles happen but
it's like am I gonna bet that like I
mean have you seen Hollywood the last 10
years come on come on you know you know
they're all cheating so it's like my
whole my whole point is not that
cheating is okay I'm not saying that
cheating is good my whole point is that
women want to say that they are the
victim when a lot of times they're not
because they're doing the same [__] just
in a different way because men and women
are different thank you yeah I think
they the women doesn't have the courage
to end up or break up the relationship
Men start to behave differently and the
point I was going to end up at
communication because people are not
communicating and
I think that's this equation but of
course easy to blame women don't have
the courage to leave no 20 23. women
need courage women normally drop a guy
do you know someone who has the courage
we got to Ryan the eating Warrior for
the Super Chat he says for the sound
board with the with the uh you know the
thank you hands yeah I had to shout that
out but when I saw that bro big up to
you bro anyway I just wanted to hear
what you said
um I feel like women these days normally
leave the relationship mentally way
before the relationship has actually
ended like and I don't know about you
guys but I personally feel like as a
known fact because even with some of my
friends people I've known they're just
like over it like they're over it but
they're not kind of looking because
they've yeah they've had their headed
too long on social media and they're
dreaming about some reality that doesn't
exist
that is the question tell me one time
you guys left a job they're like I'm
unhappy I'm leaving this job and decide
to leave when have you done that before
like sales
like it's really difficult decision like
I'm gonna leave it's gonna be right now
you need a motive I think to be honest
to be honest when I when I quit my job I
just had one Tick Tock go viral and I
was like I'm gonna be an influencer and
quit I moved home did I not true story
was it hard it wasn't hard at all yeah
we got to uh they got to Despicable for
the 20 super chances question for
Pearl's mom in general terms what would
you say has been the most challenging
aspect of your marriage yep I'm divorced
shout out to King riches and the panel
great show today big up to you my bro
what's the most challenging part of
being married yeah oh that's hard that's
challenging aspect of my of your
marriage I think that
outside influences in your relationship
so family you know your kids as they
become adult kids all of those
Transitions and then I think
um transitioning through life at the
same rate you know we all evolve and so
you know if you're evolving at a
different rate I think that's also uh
that's also really hard
um but you know it's a I think you just
have to have a mentality that you're
just putting your shoulder into it it's
like I don't really care what goes wrong
I mean I do that shouldn't shouldn't say
that but you have to just be willing to
put a shoulder into it and just like do
hard things
yeah no I definitely I think like uh
that's a really good question that he
asked because I think
that people don't are not really
listening to the opinions of people who
are successful as in in relationships
and stuff like that because I would see
you as a successful because you're
married you've done it for a long time
you've raised children etc etc
successful children and stuff like that
so like obviously you're I'm gonna
listen to if if I'm in a situation where
like okay I'm thinking about marriage
and you know I'm taking this seriously
and I want to know you know what the
pitfalls are and stuff like I'm gonna
ask you but I think a lot of modern
women are asking single women or
unsuccessful women their opinions about
about I have a battery I have a better
answer actually
um it's when your kids are in pain and
you don't react to it the same because
you're both very invested in your kids
you love your kids right and so when
they are struggling you don't solve the
problem in the same way and you know if
it's like I want to you know burn
somebody's eyes out if they hurt my kid
and if we both have that opinion and
then we feel like we're both doing it
wrong that's probably the hardest thing
oh
that's interesting do you would you not
agree that a lot of times women are
taking their cues from maybe a lot of
other single women who are women that
are not in any better situation than
they are and then they're going to them
asking their opinion and they these are
the type of people that will be you know
giving you lot advice oh yeah treat your
man like that they're your coaches do
you know how many coaches on the
internet
trying like they want you to pay they're
gonna give you the success of
relationship and everything but
themselves have never achieved anything
else
yeah well what like so so do you think a
lot of modern women they're going to the
wrong sources most of the time do you
think okay let me go like this do you
think a lot of times women are lying to
women
when in terms of how to be successful in
dating and stuff like that in
relationships do you think women lie to
women a lot because I personally do yeah
100 yes yes it's because women they have
a kind of bitter competition sometimes
man doesn't but women they have this
competition like oh my husband he gave
me this you know well and I think it's a
self-absorbed perspective so you know
like it isn't just modern women it's all
women if they're if you're a traditional
woman and you've decided your heads out
you're gonna go look for the right
advice to convince yourself that it's
time to leave and that that's better for
my family it's better for me
I think that's women in general I don't
think it's Unique to to the type of
woman yeah I think that's what we do we
go look for validation for what our
perspective is and I don't think you've
got a look you don't have to look for it
what's the worst advice you ever got
from a single woman about your marriage
I mean you know there's always a leave
that's always yeah you feel like did
single women ever encourage you to leave
I mean you know I made a habit as much
as I could of not complaining out
outside of my marriage I mean obviously
you do but I would say that you know
people want you people have a desire for
likeness so I want you to want what I
want right I'm sitting here trying to
convince you both of you like please
don't do what you're doing come do what
I'm doing because I think it's better
that's what women do we all do it and so
I think that when you go to get advice
you should only go to get advice from
people that you want to Aspire to be
like not you know not the opposite
absolutely absolutely
all right this has been awesome we got
Lee Young for hitting up the cash out
appreciate that my bro big up to
um
all right why do women
usually terminate marriages
what is the reason behind that why do we
mean Instagram
why do you think women usually terminate
marriages
I mean it's complicated I think it's
boring so we were talking about you were
talking about
um that it's hard for both men and women
and marriages I think what is hard for
men they're big rocks right I have to
protect I have to provide for my family
I mean these are really big things and
women and I can say that I'm in this
group it's like you feel like you're
shoveling pebbles for the rest of your
[__] life and it's like you empty the
sink and it's full again and you empty
the dishwasher and it's full again and
you change the diaper and it's full
again and it's just like this it's like
I'm dating myself but it's like Laverne
and Shirley and they had like the candy
on the on the conveyor belt and it
wouldn't stop coming and I think that's
what women that's what's hard for women
it's like that that is the hard part and
then you get all the exciting stuff
right well you don't feel you know and
then if you're you know my husband isn't
good at saying like go honey thanks for
changing the diaper like that's I mean
most people don't do that because in its
in that small sector changing a diaper
doesn't you know nothing it's nothing in
the grand scheme of things you're going
to go risk your life and I'm complaining
about a diaper you know that seems like
lame except for it's that you've just
done 20 of those today you've given five
kids a bath you've done homework with
all of them you've gone to basketball
games soccer games you got the car
washed you had to go meet with the
insurance guy you know by the way one of
the kids broke a window so you called it
and so like you just feel like you're
like oh my God I can't you know I can't
come up for air and then you know he
comes home from work and he's like God
today was a shitty day and you're like
oh don't even get on me you know and so
I think that what happens is is that
it's that that's lack of being fulfilled
and so one day you realize you've looked
like a wreck for 10 years and you're
like wait I don't want to do this
anymore and so I think that's what like
the the thought process is behind it and
I'm not justifying it but I'm saying
I've seen it over and over again
um and in this world that we're in so
many you know moms including me I had a
career I had a big career I spent a lot
of time on the road Hannah knows I
traveled a lot it was really really
really hard I have tenacity I have a
work ethic that's probably been a fault
but there's a world full of people that
don't have that and so it's kind of an
unsustainable reality the women in the
world are you know they want to have
these big careers they want to have you
know maybe they don't want to have
families anymore but they want to have
all these things and it's unsustainable
and so I think that's when they're like
check mark I'm out I'm just gonna go get
rid of the easy button and the Easy
Button happens to be the the husband and
the kids
wow that's that's crazy I've never like
I've never heard it like that and it
makes I kind of see I'm kind of
understanding where
women come from where they're coming
from from your life from what you've
just said like so like you know if
you've been doing this for like 10 years
you know you've had like multiple kids
blah blah blah like that makes sense I
can I can understand I'm not saying it's
right or wrong but I can understand it
because
you know life it can be monotonous I
understand why do you why do you think
that women will think the grass is
greener on the other side
because I think the perspective that
they surround themselves by gives them
that perspective and you know when
you're in the throes of it like for me
again like my only my own perspective
it's not anybody else's but you know we
had an au pair so we had somebody that
lived in our house and helped take care
of our kids
we did that because you know my husband
was vacant he a lot of times he was gone
many many hours working crazy hours and
so you know that was the best type of
child care for our for our family
regardless of that
when I got home at night she was off
duty so here I am working all day long
doing my job and then I get home and I
work until you know I go to bed and then
you know the kids get up at night you
get up with them and I wouldn't want him
to get up with him I want to do that but
the point on all of it is just to say
that it becomes like a treadmill you
feel like you can't press the stop
button on and so you got to give
something and you've built your career
it's about you it's about you know it's
it's by you for you buy you for you and
suddenly you're like check mark I'm out
I can't do all of these things so I'm
not going to give up the one thing
that's for myself
crazy what about because that again I
understand what you're saying but I
think like a lot of times when we see
these examples of women just checking
out of their marriages and stuff A lot
of times it's not that situation a lot
of times it'll be like maybe they've
been with the guy one year two year
three year out one kid out I think they
married I think they married the
Instagram photos
they wanted to get married just to have
the
the image I mean I know a couple of
marriages that was like I agree they did
they just got married for the white
dress and the children
for the Instagram photo yeah what was he
gonna what did you think I completely
agree with her I think now Family
marriages Instagram picture when you go
to like Europe when you travel as well
you don't care about knowing the place
more
you're more concerned about the pictures
you're gonna be posting on Instagram so
do you think a lot a lot of times when
because obviously I think men do want to
get married but it's more times this
woman will be pushing for it like let's
get married let's have a kid let's have
it because the timeline in it like you
know biological clock etc etc so
like with that being said
do you feel like
I've lost my foot
bro I was trying to get it I just lost
my foot but it's crazy though like you
know like women just kind of want that
party and it's like they don't really
care about the guy that much it's like
they care about the whole Fiasco the
whole like I want to be the center of
attention on my wedding day and I want
my bridesmaids to be dressed nice but
not nicer than me and I want a big rock
on my finger and all do you think that a
lot of times so you're agree with that a
lot of women are kind of more for the
party or the theatrics of it over
actually let me actually come together
with this man and I actually love this
guy and I want to be with this guy is it
more of Life did you the party did you
ever see it on like Kevin Samuels
streams when the girls were engaged for
like two years and he's like why don't
you just go to the courthouse and get
married and then they're like oh no I
can't do that but when you think about
it a wedding's just one day a marriage
is the rest of your life like who gives
who cares about the wedding but do you
think they actually
were that complicated like in my head
and maybe this is wrong they it isn't
that they were thinking he is not
valuable after the wedding they haven't
even thought about after the wedding
they're just like you know they're all
like rainbows and unicorns about this
wedding and then afterwards they're like
should I have to roll over and look at
this guy for the next 50 years yeah and
that to me and maybe I want to always
see the best in people so maybe that's
uh no I agree with that when I was Nani
I could see by the pictures and but the
lifestyle they had before the marriage
and after the marriage and children and
some of that is like uh taking a list
I need it tick tick tick and once they
have they don't know what to do they are
not complete they are not happy some of
them some are really happy some of my
friends got married my sister she's
super happy but it's not all the cases
some of them is truly to show off
because I think relationship those days
became a goal if you can keep a
relationship you're already winning in a
society we're living because it's super
rare for you to keep a relationship to
have a good relationship with your
family is also a challenge so a lot of
people when they have this relationship
is all what the people would say I think
people really care about you especially
women sing Single and a certain age they
feel insecure they feel afraid what
people will say and I think it's more
what people would say that what I'm
feeling
because
well if they get married and divorced at
least they prove they were it's
desirable
divorce I fail as a woman I fail as a
mother it's it's really complicated for
you to assume when you when you fail in
something and in my opinion A
relationship is not failures it's about
working together or not
I just think like people need help like
narcissistic parents now all over on
Tick Tock a lot of victims came step in
and say how harsh they had to be growing
up a certain kind of parents
but yeah I think it's it's more about
you understand what you feel but not
caring about the outside it's really
difficult it's really difficult to be a
women and single people of course like
if you're married with the family people
or the respected Woman married with
Children so don't you don't you because
you just said it's hard to not think
about what the outside thinks right for
most of the people so so don't you think
that not having Instagram would be
beneficial for a marriage because then
you're not thinking as much about what
the outside thinks no 100 for me social
media which person would they have like
I work with that so I I have nowhere
Escape I work with this but for most of
people's option I I know a lot of guys
in London they have no Facebook no
Instagram at all I know a lot of people
who doesn't have any but you see why I
went earlier we're asking if you delete
your Instagram to a guy it's like if
you're willing to just get rid of it
easy it's it's better for the marriage
and a lot of times like girls think of
it as controlling but it's really just a
guy looking out for the relation
friendship in my opinion he is a bit
controlling because like especially in
Brazil like the clothes you're wearing
the boyfriends they want to tell you
what to do where to go who to see but
see you you see it as controlling and I
think a lot of women do but guys are
looking at it as that like you're their
woman they want to protect you like we
look to them to protect and provide and
a lot of times they protect us from
ourselves because we might not look at a
certain outfit and think Hmm oh that's
like that's like gonna draw the wrong
attention to me but men know how other
men think I know I agree but like her
she's a dancer she is her job I work
with social media so to approach people
to be talking to people I need to be
online so I would say certain kinds of
jobs and certain it's not a question
it's like how much how much do you guys
like what you make thousands of dollars
from social media oh no no I work in the
corporate side I don't work with my page
as an influencer I'm not a new phone no
no so that's that's what I'm saying like
a lot of times like girls are so
attached to their so social media and
it's like how much do you even really
make from it so for me it's more in my
network because well as a Public
Relation when you need to approach
someone like they'd like to see what
you're doing and I see I see what you're
saying but like my whole my whole point
is like you know that's not something
that you can't do with email like I
worked in Corporate America you can you
can use a LinkedIn and email there's
ways around it but it's just to a guy
when you're constantly questioning his
judgment it's just hard for him to work
with sorry to interrupt but in terms of
lack you see how she said because I
thoughts and stuff like even when I'm
going out like and you say your thoughts
I'll be like oh let me see your
Instagram let me see your work on
Instagram it's just like it's like it's
by force to kind of have it like they
see it as a portfolio like if that's
like your way of doing your job and how
you get your bookings and stuff that's
what I learned and I and I understand
that but I was just looking at your page
today I didn't I barely even saw those
new rules babe no but
there's rules in the main part and and
if it was marketed as like a strictly
dancing professional Pages our model as
well that's why like I I get booking's
modeling and for dancing so there's
that's why it varies okay I I I don't
know your life but I know I know I'm
just I'm telling you how men would see
it
and you can you could say oh men won't
see it that way but we're in a room full
of men I you could ask them how they
would see it okay we'll do that later
after this we will definitely meet up
because let me just uh shout out the
super Chatters man we got two uh big boy
702 he said that he's out we got to him
we got to Brandon Slaughter he says Big
Ups two King Rich's shout out to your
mom Pearl very classy too bad I'm only
five eleven
can we make 511
we'll see what other options we got
first oh
we got to Ryan the eating Warrior again
for another Super Chat he says I was
deployed and my ex-wife made friends
with modern American women and ended up
going to bars and sleeping with a dude
we divorced last month sad she threw our
marriage of five years away one night
over one night but I'm finally moving on
I big up to you man and listen bro like
just keep your head up man like you know
what I mean your life is not over and
keep pushing Brian and just make
yourself happy bro like thank you for
your service and thank you for your
service for the Americans I'm not
American but you know I was born on
Veterans Day so I'm like really
patriotic like carrying the flag oh okay
all right but yeah man like definitely
just let's live your movie bro and like
make the most of your life and you know
what more than likely your life is gonna
be better than her so I'm just being
real real life is more than likely going
to be better than hers in the long run
so you know I mean
um all right I got I got another
question yeah um why do you think
many men uh in Brackets passport Bros
are leaving the West to find wives in
other countries why do you why do you
think guys a lot of guys like probably
in America and the UK are leaving to go
to find go to other countries to find
women like South America Asia Africa
stuff Caribbean maybe like why do you
think guys are doing that
they might prefer their culture their
cultural how they behave they might
prefer it like I don't know what country
are you from
oh Grenada and Ivory Coast okay would
you what what would you say like the
general culture is like over there like
what are the women like over there
I don't know much well
the crap like traditional traditional
yeah traditional people like like would
you what in what ways like cooking
cleaning kind of just
looking after the home I mean the
Caribbean side it varies
but yeah like the African side from like
my friends that I've already and I've
seen how they're mums and how they they
behave with their husbands and stuff
yeah because there's this because
there's a big movement of passport Bros
and like obviously guys that are
watching you've more than likely heard
about it even it was funny because even
one of my good good friends and he's a
guy that does really well with women and
he was talking about it today
and he said he's probably watching right
now and he was like yeah yeah man I'm
passport Bros as well do you understand
and this is a guy that does well he's a
Tyro and certified like do you know what
I'm saying so it's just like I think a
lot of modern women in our side of the
world they're not really understanding
they're not really understanding that
you are losing that like do you get what
I'm saying not you personally but a lot
of a lot of women are losing that would
you not think about passport Bros
um I think they go over you know as
someone that grew up with nannies from
around the world I just say they're
better overall non-western women they
tend to be more submissive they tend to
be in better shape
and I think for a lot of guys they have
to deal with a bunch of [__] from
women here so they're like you know what
if I can just go find a woman that's
easier she's more submissive and she
wants out to be a wife and a mother I'm
just gonna go do that I think that we
could as American women learn from the
women there I'm going to tell you
something okay and UK women as well I'm
gonna tell you a story so there is a
woman in I think Thailand or something
she wasn't sleeping with her husband
okay she wasn't she had like postpartum
depression and all this stuff and she
felt so guilty about not sleeping with
her husband that she put an ad for it to
have a girl come in and live with them
and be part of the family and like sleep
sleep with her husband he didn't know
about any of this there were thousands
of women that applied for this ad Okay
thousands because they would be rent
free whatever like it'd be she'd be like
a part of the family she just had to
sleep with him whatever what percent of
American women care so much about making
their man happy they would be willing to
swallow their pride and let another
woman live in their home
now I'm not advocating doing that I
think that's a bit odd but the point is
the mindset they care so much about
their husband's happiness that she was
willing to do that
that's the point it's not it's not that
that's a weird dynamic I would you know
but the whole point is that they want to
make their match she wants to make her
man happy so bad that he didn't even ask
her to do that she did that on her own
and I just think that you know that we
can learn something from that we can
look at the countries whatever I wonder
if the man will be that eagle to make
his woman that happy because that's
that's a lot oh he oh he responds he
responded like he um it was funny
because they asked him about him they
interviewed him and he was like yeah I
had no idea but I'm down like you ask
you ask a man can I get a hot young
thing and living with me I think a lot
are gonna say yeah it's crazy I mean if
the rules were
was switched I mean like if the man's
working too much he's traveling around
right is he really gonna go and make an
ad for a man to come and never do with
your woman because because I mean
actually because because again men and
women are different it's not the same
but we still have the same needs now
look at throughout history men haven't
been around so this idea that like men
have always been in the house they used
to work in the freaking coal mines what
are you gonna you think your husband's
around they used to work like 12 hour
days on the farm in the fields they
weren't we didn't live in this you know
utopian society where men and women were
just together all the time we thought
about being together all the time but I
I think the idea here is that like like
even even this this mindset here it's
like immediately when we talk about a
man's need we always switch it to the
woman no but this situation is a switch
because both the man and the woman will
need wool she didn't want it no because
she said about her she didn't need me
I'm not talking about her
is whenever whenever we bring up
whenever we bring up a a story where we
have to talk about the the man it's
always well I gotta flip it we don't
always have me I don't personally but I
did that because I really want to know
if he would go to those extents for her
like that's why I said it yeah but it
doesn't matter
that's that's unrealistic because who's
going to want to probably have sex more
it's gonna be the man so that even it
depends on the woman yeah but I don't
think that's what you were saying I
don't think it was if like he would go
to that extent to fix the postpartum
depression if he would go yeah for
taking care of the children if he would
go to that extent thank you it's not
about just the sex I mean is he willing
to go that far to make you that happy
too like that's what thank you thank you
so much
let's say in general yes um because
again when when the tables are turned
women leave and that's what we see in
the stats and the data is that the
second that the man stops providing
women leave that's one of the number one
indicators of divorce is that when a
woman out earns the husband she gets a
promotion at work she tends to leave in
general when the world women fall for
divorce most of the time where men tend
to stick it out a lot more than women do
it's just it's just the way it is from